mercury is a planet of mystery it's a
planet closest to the Sun ends important
piece from the standing how our solar
system was formed every time you send a
spacecraft to mercury we learned
something new in the 70s we found out
that mercury has a magnetic field during
the messenger machine where was a couple
of years ago found that there's water
highs and some of the craters close to
the poles also surface temperatures are
extreme near hot we need a mission like
Pepe Colombo to sir only investigate
this planet
[Music]
barbra Colombo is a to spacecraft
mission and the aim of the mission is to
better understand mercury in its
environment so looking at its magnetic
field its atmosphere its composition and
its interaction with the Sun it's the
first ever two spacecraft mission to go
to the planet Mercury and so this is
going to be taking really unique data
set but we've never had the opportunity
to look at before to visit mercury is
extremely challenging from a technology
point of view mercury isn't really that
far away but as it happens it's very
hard to get your spacecraft to slow down
enough to actually be able to be
captured into orbit around mercury the
other obvious challenge is the extreme
environment at spacecraft has to endure
our instruments have to be designed to
operate in 400 degrees centigrade but
also have to be able to operate in the
solar system on the journey on the way
to mercury including going past Venus
and going past mercury on a number of
flybys
to build a spacecraft that can stand
this heat is a significant challenge
that we have mastered in Pepe Colombo
there was a lot of thought heartache
energy and then progressively over the
years to see it develop into a
structural thermal model and finally to
the flight model is a quite an amazing
experience the launch is planned for
October 2018
bepi itself then begins a whole new
phase with its 7 years to mercury and
then two years of operation in mercury
orbit I've worked for 15 years on this
mission and so this launch is all or
nothing
[Music]
mercury is an important member of the
solar system because it's closest to the
Sun and this is an incredibly important
mission because we will send two
spacecraft there to study how the Sun
interacts with that planet and how the
planet may have formed and evolved over
time
[Music]
you